5 millions de rendez vous pour se faire
vacciner contre le coz ide dans les
quinze jours une annonce de jean castex
il s'agit de faire face au spectre d'une
quatrième vague épidémique
il ya dix-huit mille nouvelles
contaminations la plus forte hausse
jamais enregistrée
le premier ministre s'est exprimé chez
nos confrères de tf1 dans la foulée d'un
conseil de défense sanitaire tout cela
le jour de l'entrée en vigueur de la
première étape du pass sanitaire est dès
aujourd'hui il faudra donc présenté son
pass ou un test négatif de -2 48 heures
pour pouvoir entrer dans de nombreux
lieux accueillant plus de 50 personnes
comme les salles de spectacle et cinéma
les lieux de culte et d'autres osent
encore le projet de loi est débattue
aujourd'hui par les députés avant
d'arriver au sénat demain et des appels
à manifester contre le passe à nous
taire devant l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat circule sur les réseaux sociaux
le projet de loi du gouvernement qui
sera étudiée aujourd'hui à 15 heures
puis 21h30 à l'assemblée avant donc un
passage jeudi et vendredi devant le
sénat on va retrouver justement
l'assemblée net devant l'assemblée
nationale notre reporter katia technique
katia bonjour alors se passe à lui tard
il est loin de faire l'unanimité sion
en effet 1 samantha de très nombreux
députés s'opposent se passe sanitaires
et d'autres au contraire sont pour mais
ils vont déposer énormément
d'amendements pour entraver au minimum
les libertés individuelles ils tiennent
beaucoup à cela même du côté des
républicains
en revanche dans la plupart des cas ils
sont pour la vaccination
voir pour vaccination obligatoire pour
davantage de type professionnel alors un
vos proches a été fait hier en
commission olivier ferrand le ministre
de la santé plus tard dans l'hémicycle à
jean castex le premier ministre pourquoi
imposer un pass sanitaire alors que même
que tout même si de nombreux français
souhaitent vacciner et bien ils n'ont
pas accès à des doses à cause d'une
pénurie alors jean castex aujourd'hui
s'est exprimé sur tf1 expliquant que
bientôt 5 millions de 2,5 millions de
rendez vous allez être organisé ces
prochains jours je propose de l'écouter
dans les quinze jours qui viennent on va
ouvrir 5 millions de rendez vous dans
cette perte s'est pas seulement ouvrir
pour vous dire vous aurez rendez vous le
20 août d'abord quels objectifs on a eu
bien compris vous mettez l'accent sur la
vaccination mais l'objectif alors
chiffré ces 40 millions de primo
vacciner à la fin de ce mois on est
bientôt un premier oui sauf que c'était
40 millions fin août
mais on parlera et 50 millions fin août
bayer est là pour vous dire cette
semaine on devrait sceller primo
vaccination c'est votre question on
devra en faire deux millions il a
également annoncé une semaine de
pédagogie pour la mise en place du pass
sanitaires et ensuite place aux
sanctions pour ceux qui ne
respecteraient pas les contrôles il ya
fort à faire pour déployer une pédagogie
temps de nombreux professionnels sont
hostiles et de nombreux citoyens
également à se passe jean castex a
précisé quelques détails il n'y aura pas
de passe sanitaires dans les
établissements scolaires en revanche les
restaurateurs par exemple les patrons de
bars les lieux culturels de
bien le contrôle et en revanche ne
contrôlons pas l'identité des clients
quant à richard ferrand il vient il ne
veut pas du passé sanitaires pour
filtrer l'entrée de l'assemblée
nationale le pass anitea c'est bon pour
les autres la raison la mesure ne serait
pas invalidée par le conseil
constitutionnel
autre information du jour à concernant
l' opposition à ce texte
une manifestation a lieu en ce moment
même devant l'assemblée nationale
de nombreux protestataires sont arrivés
avec des porte voix et des affiches pour
contester ce pas sanitaires bien sûr et
la diminution des libertés individuelles
merci à vocation technique pour toutes
ces précisions